[Applause]
it's time i share something
extraordinary from social media this is
what i'm liking
[Music]
in 2018 while surfing in hawaii doug
lost his beloved
custom surfboard and a massive wave then
get this
it was found two years later 5 000 miles
away
the board ended up in the hands of a
local school teacher in the philippines
who amazingly was able to track doug
down
now the two men have formed a bond and
are working together for a great cause
let's get doug on the line everybody
what's up doug
hi kelly what's up man so tell us about
the surfboard and how you managed to
find it
so the surfboard happened to be shaped
by an amazing surfer
and it wasn't cheap i saved up money um
to buy it it was the most expensive
thing i owned at the time
um i finally surfed on it enough
where i came to end up losing
it um and that was devastating to me you
know
it really bummed me out um lo and behold
uh i'm waking up one morning
and i find a picture posted on instagram
with my name tagged on it and it
happened to be a picture of that
surfboard
wow i mean first of all i got to tell
you what
carrying that damn thing looks hard let
alone surfing with it like i'm like
how do you carry it um and now you're
close friends right
yeah so javon the teacher who who has my
board
um we've been talking a lot and um
after time went by i i said hey you know
what
like you you bought this board to surf
it and you want to learn how to surf
um i so i just thought you know i'd send
him surf supplies
well his first reaction was don't do
that
can you send me magazines so my students
can learn
to read english so i said well
i think i could do better than that um
since this story is getting so much
exposure
i thought i'd do a gofundme and from
then until now
i've raised about seven thousand dollars
for his students
wow isn't that crazy that's must be the
best
purchase of your life that to really
transform everything
yeah it's the best best feeling to be
able to to help
you know people who i think might be
more unfortunate than we are
i know but just to purchase i was
talking about the surfboard you
purchased that surfboard you put all
that money you saved
you lose it and then it ends up being
like the best money ever spent in such a
different way
yeah the best fifteen hundred dollars i
ever lost
yeah well thank you so much doug and
thank you for all that you're doing it's
a it's a really beautiful thing what
you're doing right now for
for his students thank you so much i'm
liking your post right now right
thank you thank you for having me
absolutely well that's not all this
season we've actually partnered with
pilot
g2 pin the go-to pin at the kelly
clarkson show and they want to recognize
great people doing great things
um so they're gonna give you a thousand
dollars oh no way that's amazing
awesome well thank you so much doug have
a blessed day all right
thank you want more fun stuff i thought
so
check out these videos floating around
my head this one is really cool
i'm just saying no pressure